her health it does leave one very tired
and exhausted doesn't it the softly
softly approach to transition has been
happening for some time prince charles
placing her wreath at the cenotaph
prince william representing her on
overseas tours
she is not stepping away but this is a
moment where she appreciates her heirs
must symbolically step in
well let's talk now to former black rod
david leakey who's here in the studio
with me and um
there's actually a lot already going on
in parliament this morning isn't there
just talk us through some of the
ceremonial things that have been
happening the traditional things that
have been going on
one of the first uh ceremonies that
takes place in the morning is the
ceremonial search of the sellers of the
palace of westminster
and this uh
commemorates i suppose you could say the
failed gunpowder plot by guy fawkes when
there was an attempt to blow up
parliament
and so on the day that the sovereign
comes to parliament there is a
ceremonial search of the sellers to make
sure there isn't a repeat of that the
interesting thing about this year's
ceremony and and there are a number of
firsts for state opening of parliament
this year uh the first is of course that
prince charles will be reading the
queen's speech
um but another first is that the um the
ceremonial search is led by um by one of
the estate staff who carries a great big
key which unlocks the cellar doors
allegedly
and uh normally that's been a man in
fact um for centuries it has been a man
and but today for the first time it is a
woman and it's um
mary jane sang
and she's been on the estate staff um in
parliament for a number of years and
one of her major responsibilities is in
fact looking after all the furnishings
she's an expert in
the particularly the antique furnishings
and fabrics in parliament uh and so
she's a lot there is a lot and she has a
lot to do with the
um preparing uh the chamber for the
state opening of parliament to make sure
that the throne and the fabric of the
throne are all cleaned and and
positioned correctly and so she's got
this great big key does the is the key
actually used or is it just a sort of
ceremonial keyboard possibly that would
be a secret far too shortly secret to
declare
it is much it is a very largely
ceremonial occasion uh and uh and it
concludes um so the the
the the um
the german waters
form up in prince's chamber just outside
the house of lords chamber just
as it were behind the throne and they
form up in a line and um they each have
a lantern on on the on the floor in
front of them
and the lanterns are lit
and then they ceremonially step forward
and pick up the lanterns and then they
turn to their left and they [ __ ] off
slowly and they go down the stairs and
into the cellars
and there's a ceremonial route and they
eventually emerge on the terrace of the
house of lords and are these lanterns
are they are they modern lanterns or are
they old oh they're called
um
they are not candlelit anymore no um but
they are quite antique yes and the other
thing that that happens today that
people may not be aware of is that when
the monarch is due to come to parliament
for this occasion an mp is is kidnapped
in inverted commas and and and taken to
buckingham palace what tell us about
that and who is it this year yes
this is the the vice chamberlain um one
of the junior whips in the government is
um uh gets a a a nominal role an
honorary role um of vice chamberlain it
makes him a member actually of the royal
household
and
because of the fractious relationship um
particularly dating back to the years of
charles the first between the crown and
parliament um
there
it was it was seen as helpful to the
crown if a member of parliament was as
it were taken hostage
um into the royal palace which now is
buckingham palace and and so that's what
happens and so the vice chamberlain i
can't remember his name off top of my
head but he's a junior whip
and um and he will be taken to
buckingham palace as hostage for the
duration of
uh the ceremony james morris empty james
i've got my note to hand and what
happens
when he's there i mean i know you know i
don't care any secrets but i mean is he
is he just popped into a room and given
a cup of tea or is he thrown into the
cellars well i think this is something
that he should be asked when he comes
out because it's um another of those
great state secrets whether he is i mean
there are stories that the the um
uh that he's filled up with gin and
tonic to the point where he can't return
to the chamber sober uh and others where
he's been deprived even of a drink of
water
or a television screen to watch the
parliament so it's um anything on the
spectrum between those two
and when we think about the
the role of the queen and and the links
between the queen and the government and
parliament
when when the the house of lords was
rebuilt
the fact that the queen does this or the
k or the king at the time does this
a whole party was built for it wasn't it
the sovereign's entrance the robbing
rooms just for this ceremony today this
is
kind of the key moment between the
monarchy and parliament isn't it it is
and and there are two things you you
mentioned the the physical surroundings
the roping room the royal gallery in
particular
um
um it was until 1965 a lot of people
don't know this uh the palace of
westminster was actually owned by the
sovereign
um and it was
during the prime ministership of harold
wilson in i think 1964 or 65
that the queen it was the queen's
initiative that she thought it was wrong
that the sovereign should actually own
and manage
the
um particularly the house of commons the
democratic elected chamber
of parliament and um at a meeting with
harold wilson she put the proposal that
she should hand over
the respective parts of the palace of
westminster to the house of commons and
to the house of lords for them to manage
and control themselves and and that was
agreed and it was done by um a statement
in in the respective chambers in the
house of lords in the house of commons
and so in fact the palace is is
in if you were to look on the land
registry but it's not on the land
registry you would see it's in three
different ownerships and the house of
commons owns its end so the big ben end
of the palace of westminster where the
house of commons chamber is the house of
lords owns um its chamber and the
officers up uh towards the victoria
tower end
of the palace of westminster but the
sovereign has retained in the palace of
westminster the robin gallery uh the
robbing room and the royal gallery and
in fact westminster hall which is right
down at the big ben end um why
westminster hall uh for two reasons
partly because there is a chapel um the
crypt chapel which is one of the most
beautiful chapels in london with also
one of the best small organs in london
as well
well worth a visit if you get the chance
that is a royal peculiar it's used every
day um by parliamentarians for worship
and and choirs and so on um but the
chapel there still belongs to
belongs to the sovereign and westminster
hall because that is where one
occasionally we have great state
occasions so the lying in states of for
example the queen mother
takes place in westminster hall and that
is still under the control of the
sovereign and so you have these the
building owned by three people and those
are the same or three
elements of our constitution
and those are the same three elements
that come today uniquely on the day of
state opening of parliament so the three
parts of our constitutional legislature
the house of commons the house of lords
which some people call the advisory or
revising chamber
and the sovereign who as it were signs
off uh legislation into law
so it's a physical manifestation so it's
a physical manifestation of the three
elements of our constitution coming
together
very interesting thank you very much
learning something every day well
rhiannon mills uh our royal
correspondent is uh outside parliament
for us now uh let's just bring her in
rihanna a very different day today isn't
it um are we going to have to get used
to this do we do we think seeing prince
charles and prince william becoming
a lot more visible within the royal
family
well i think there's there's a few
things that we need to unpick when it
comes to this decision that was made by
the queen herself yesterday i think she
really wanted to be here this is a key
part of her constitutional role uh a
moment that has punctuated her her 70
year reign but it was decided that
actually it was probably
a bit too much because again this is one
of those big occasions where she would
be expected to walk quite a distance she
is 96 years old we know that she has
been having ability problems also the
speech normally takes about eight
minutes she'd be expected to sit for
that so i think in the end it was
decided that this actually was
the moment where this key responsibility
had to be handed over what was really
interesting yesterday was talking to
constitutional experts who were
fascinated as to how exactly she was
going to do this because there's been so
much discussion uh in recent weeks um
boris johnson is now leaving downing
street uh on his way to the palace of
westminster and we will shortly of
course see also prince charles and
prince william heading
in this direction because it was through
a letter's patent that the queen decided
that as her counsellors of state she was
going to hand over the responsibility of
opening parliament what's been really
interesting though is all of the
messaging that's been coming from the
palace since we found out about that
announcement last night the fact that
they are saying that yes it is going to
be prince charles who is going to be
reading that speech on her behalf the
first time that another member of the
royal family has done that during her
70-year reign the other two occasions
that she wasn't able to attend the state
opening of parliament it was the lord
chancellor who read the speech on her
behalf today it's going to be her son
and heir but also it's going to be the
first time that the duke of cambridge is
going to attend a state opening of
parliament and what the palace has very
been very clearly been saying is that
yes prince charles is reading the speech
but it's a joint responsibility the
opening of parliament william and
charles are doing this jointly as
councillors of state so i think all of
the discussion
in the newspapers today about whether
we're seeing a regency whether we're
seeing a prince regent situation at the
palace trying to pour water on that fire
saying yes this lettuce patent uh was
signed and authorized by the queen for
this one occasion no other
responsibilities are being handed over
at the moment so you can see the
constitution having to flex and change
and that's what's going to get
constitutional experts so excited about
today and that is why this is a defining
moment but you're talking about the
constitution changing and flexing to do
with an aging monarch and not an
abdicating monarch and at the start of
her platinum jubilee year in her
accession day message the queen very
clearly said she is still continuing to
pledge to serve her country and
commonwealth but i think again common
sense has prevailed and the palace the
queen herself has decided now is the
right time maybe just for this year
we'll have to wait and see but now is
the right time to hand over this
significant responsibility to her heirs
and rhiannon
skycopter is trained on buckingham
palace that of course is the queen's
traditional route do we do we think that
um prince charles and prince william
will will take the same route because
there's been a great deal of rehearsals
uh from the army and from all the
different regiments who take part in in
lining that route
jane it's what's been fascinating is
just a couple of days ago we had a very
detailed what we call an operational
note talking about how the different
armed forces were going to be involved
in today and also within that
operational note it talked about how the
queen would move from buckingham palace
here to the palace of westminster and
talk about how it was going to be
different from previous years because
again to make sure that she was
comfortable she would be traveling by
car
we wait and find out exactly how it's
going to work when it comes to prince
charles and prince william and also the
duchess of cornwall because she is going
to be accompanying
the prince of wales how exactly they
travel here to westminster there has
already been some maneuvering some
movements around buckingham palace range
rovers have been seen so it is
potentially likely that they will
leave buckingham palace we do know that
the imperial state crown will still form
part of the procession but also i think
what's going to be fascinating to watch
is is the optics like the pictures
around this are going to be so important
so are we going to see prince william
and prince charles traveling in the same
car if they want to hammer home that
message that this isn't a regency this
isn't prince charles stepping directly
into the shoes of the monarch you would
think they would want that image of
prince william and prince charles
alongside each other but of course the
duchess of cornwall also has to travel
here
as well so we wait and see exactly how
they're going to conduct that element
of the ceremony but as i say the
imperial state crown is still going to
form
part of the procession we also know that
neither charles nor william are going to
be wearing the state robe again showing
that this is not them stepping into the
shoes
directly of the monarch and also when we
see
prince charles reading that speech i
think a really striking image that we'll
see is that the throne that the queen
would usually sit in that is going to
remain empty so again showing us that
yes
they are stepping in but she is
certainly not stepping down
rhiannon thank you very much so we're
just seeing police outriders arriving
outside buckingham palace so we'll keep
an eye on these shots while we bring in
tessa dunlop royal historian and author
who's also joining us this morning um
tessa the queen has only missed two
uh parliaments she's opened them all ah
before we we bring you in tessa let's
just see if we can train our eyes on
these cars coming out now
and spot who is travelling and in which
order
david leahy
so the first car you see coming out is
carrying the this state the imperial
state crown the second car
um with the state regalia that is the
sword
uh the state sword ceremonial sword
and this is exactly
the same
timing and root and procession as would
have happened if the queen had been
taken apart herself it's also the same
route and procession uh if they had been
in horse-drawn carriages
um
not to be
a plot spoiler but the next car that you
will see coming out of buckner palace
will have um the duke of
cambridge on his own or at least maybe
with his private secretary but and the
duke of cambridge in a car
and then
that'll be the second procession as it
were and then the third will be the
prince of wales will with the duchess of
cornwall
and there will be a few minutes
separation between each of those three
thank you for that that's really clear
let's bring in tessa dunlop um tessa
i was just putting to you that the queen
has only missed two of these occasions
since she has has been uh on the throne
1959 and 1963 just just tell us why they
were missed
well they were missed because she was
pregnant with andrew and edward
respectively um it's worth bearing in
mind that her father and her grandfather
both missed state openings of parliament
george v in 1929 and 1935 and george vi
in 1951.
excuse me what's interesting is that in
all those cases and i'm stepping in for
the queen it was the lord chancellor the
big change here is that the prince of
wales backed by the duke of cambridge in
their role as councillors of state will
be in proxy for the sovereign herself
and one of the reasons for this is
actually that under tony blair's reform
of the lords the lord chancellor is no
longer an exalted office of state in
fact i think it's sort of been shoved
into the ministry of justice
dominic rabb currently occupies it so
therefore um there's been a change if
you like and it's not just because you
know is this an idea of bringing charles
moore into the fray but it's a
constitutional decision based on those
modifications to the lord chancellor's
role
uh what what do you do you think that
the queen's thoughts will be on the fact
that she is unable to attend today
i think um there will be a sadness a
poignancy and i think there will be also
to an extent a sense of inevitability
she's a very practical woman i work
extensively with her generation women
over 95 and they are daily um coming to
terms with physical loss um and uh
depletion of of of their former physical
abilities
and what's interesting is of course we
saw many modifications to this state
ceremony over the last few years the
imperial crown which the queen said
herself rather riley in her style you
know if you if you put it on wrong or if
you look down to read your notes it
could break your neck it's well over a
kilogram in weight it was modified it
was the current version was um
formed for her father george vi and then
it was lowered and made to look more
feminine for the queen herself but still
it weighs a ton it has nearly 3 000
precious stones so she's forgone wearing
that in the past so too we saw her last
year not in ceremonial robe and backed
up of course by the prince of wale and
camilla his wife so there's a sort of
incremental set change that's occurring
every year and it's worth bearing in
mind while this is all very new to us
because of course the queen has walked
alongside us for all i think everyone in
this country can't really remember a
time when she wasn't walking alongside
us
in fact britain has because we have a
hereditary monarchy has got very used to
monarchs who live and die in office and
therefore worth mentioning again that
her father and her grandfather missed
the stape opening of parliament in their
time as well
indeed and it was been missed six times
since uh 1901 and the fact that she has
been on the throne for 70 of those years
and that she's only missed it twice
um certainly shows her uh the duty that
she has put before all things during
during her reign
it does actually mark her extraordinary
physical stamina i mean if an individual
just thinks have i ever been ill at
christmas generally we can say oh yes we
were one christmas this is effectively
sort of an annual occurrence and the
queen's just missed it twice when she
was pregnant so really remarkable
physical health is what she's enjoyed
for so long
tessa dunlop thanks very much for the
time being uh let's bring in uh former
sky news political editor you may have
seen him before and presenter adam
bolton he is now joining us as a
political commentator uh lovely to talk
to you today adam he's down on abingdon
green for us today adam just just remind
us politically what is the point of the
queen's speech
well it is the agenda for debate in
parliament for the next year i.e the
legislation which the government wants
to put into law but i think politically
this government like so many before has
timed uh the queen's speech to come just
after local elections which didn't go so
brilliantly so in political terms what
the government wants to do is to publish
and republish and re-emphasize its
priorities
for uh the voters and it's very clear
that the messages are going to be
familiar ones from boris johnson ones
that he believes have helped him uh win
his majority particularly in the
so-called red wall former uh blue collar
labor seats so it's going to be a big
stress on leveling up
and there's going to be a big stress on
cutting red tape particularly
cutting red tape as a result of brexit
i.e getting rid of european laws so that
if you like is the propaganda message
going out many people may actually
question
whether
the substance
adds up to a great deal but then the
government also has to deal with
problems at the moment so there's going
to be this clamp down on the sort of
demonstrations we've seen with
extinction rebellion
and its various splinter movements
so that the police will have more powers
over protests lots of concern in civil
rights areas
as to quite how widely those powers
might be used once they get on the
statute books but at the same time the
government is dropping some of the
regulations which it had previously
announced so for example we're not going
to get further regulation uh sort of off
foot
to preside over british professional
football that's
been dropped
similarly
in other areas we've seen
measures for example
to
go in strong against the northern irish
protocol we believe that has been
withdrawn from the queen's speech so
while this is trying to send out a
message
of
the government's intent particularly
with those voters who supported it in
2019
it's not necessarily in practice going
to make that much difference
particularly because there are a number
of bills which the government previously
promised half a dozen which are going to
have to be carried over
so that the government can get those on
the statute books but the message is
this is the government you voted for in
2019
and they hope that it still appeals to
the voters to the same extent
and i'm just going to pause you there
because we're just looking at images of
the first procession of cars arriving at
the palace of westminster and david
leakey is with me and this rather
incongruous image of it of some of the
royal regalia sort of sticking out the
window a bit like when you go to the tip
and you you've got something that's a
bit too long and you have to poke it out
the back window surely this was not the
plan uh
i don't know about going to the tip it
reminds me of the end caption for the
antiques roadshow i think
um no so that the
there are three cars in this procession
in the first car was the imperial state
crown and you saw it
pulling up at sovereign's entrance
and the
the crown jeweler
takes the crown out of the car and takes
it in fact to a small room just inside
the sovereign's entrance where he checks
it over and gives it a last a last buff
up before it is taken up to the royal
gallery and the robbing room the um
what you're seeing now on your screens
are the mesas of the two sergeants at
arms uh who accompany the imperial state
crown
and they are if you like the close
protection uh the sergeant-at-arms for
uh the imperial state crown so that's
what you're seeing there the two mesas
and the two sergeants at arms
uh and they will um escort the the
imperial state crown
and
when it was horse drawn in a large
carriage that it was partially designed
to accommodate them a normal car not
quite so much um possibly though um i
must say that
as black crowd i was always inside the
palace never saw what went on down at
sovereignty sovereign's entrance um so
it may be that they were sticking out of
the windows of the carriages we'll have
to look back at the footage the third
car or in fact um the second car in that
procession um was carrying um the state
regalia and the state regalia consists
of
an artifact called the cap of
maintenance
and the sword of state and there's quite
a long historical significance behind
those two items the sword is rather more
self-explanatory a cap of maintenance
would take a longer time another time to
explain i think okay
let's return to our role correspondent
rhiannon mills um rhiannon
we talk about it as being the queen's
speech of course the queen doesn't
actually write it
what impact does she though have on it
in the sense that she does
meet regularly with the prime ministers
and has met regularly with so many over
her time
she does and and what's been interesting
since it was announced that the prince
of wales is carrying out the duty today
of
reading that speech that the palace
yesterday were pointing to the fact that
it is still the queen who will have a
virtual meeting of the privy council
this week it is still the queen who will
have that weekly conversation with the
prime minister and
when you speak to
prime ministers from the past they talk
about how she has always been a
wonderful
sounding board she has always
appreciated that the pressures that they
endure when it comes to being in that
position of power but also the fact that
she always politically keeps her views
to herself but has always been a
wonderful source of of counsel uh and
advice uh if they've needed it but yeah
you're correct as you say
it is a speech that is written by the
government and the queen reads out uh on
their behalf and of course the prince of
wales in recent years
with the duchess of cornwall has
accompanied the monarch so he will be
very familiar with the ceremony that we
are witnessing today but it is going to
be the first time that the duke of
cambridge is going to attend a state
opening of parliament and in some ways
you could say it's it's an ongoing
apprenticeship for for both heirs to the
throne and for prince william today this
is this is another
learning element that he will see for
himself exactly the the duty that he may
well have to have to perform himself
uh in in years to come
it is going to be i think a real
defining moment for the monarchy today
it's going to be a very
striking image amongst the very
traditional setting of the house of
lords to see
um
two heirs son and grandson performing
this duty on behalf of the queen and
while the palace they insist that is
still the queen who's carrying out those
constitutional duties that today is a
one-off that it is simply one letters
patent that's been authorized and signed
by the queen there are no other duties
that have been handed over
i think in some ways it is it is showing
us
a glimpse of what we all see
in the future because the prince of
wales is of course
the queen's heir and
prince william is prince charles's heir
so we're looking at the line of
succession today
and as the queen has done so often in
recent years she is handing over
responsibilities we are seeing
transition in the making and that has
been a very softly softly approach uh
over recent years so for example the
prince of wales placing the queen's
wreath at the at the cenotaph uh various
members of the royal family carrying out
investitures or carrying out overseas
tours and the queen very much central to
making sure that the monarchy
continues to be to be relevant
and continues to perform the duties that
is expected of the monarchy today she is
unable to be here in person because of
mobility problems but she has used
all of the the tools at her disposal to
make sure that other members of her
family can make sure that the monarchy
is here able to open parliament and see
the parliamentary the government work
continue and the new parliamentary
session open today in the way that it
should
thanks brian as you talk as we're
talking to you uh we're looking outside
the house of lords a very large guard of
honour 96 rank and file first battalion
cold stream guards there also
accompanied by the band of the cold
stream guards we don't know if we would
hear from them today
they're
up by the sovereign's entrance to former
a further layer of security there uh the
cold stream guards of course identified
by that that red plume in their best
skin caps and their scarlet tunic with
gold buttons
uh let's return to tessa dunlop royal
historian and author and tessa rhiannon
was was talking about the differences
between the queen abdicating just
explain to us what we've we've heard the
term today uh this is very different
from from a region just could you
explain to us what that is and how it is
different to what is happening today
the only time britain's um he had a
regency was actually under george iii
um and you had prince regent who later
became george iv and that was because
george iii um had um
occasional and and then more persistent
um loss of his mental faculties and
therefore his son stepped in officially
full-time
the queen is
fully in control of her mental faculties
and because of modern technology is more
than able of course to hold meetings
with the privy council with her prime
minister virtually on the telephone and
indeed if they come to her in person and
therefore i don't envisage and she
clearly doesn't either that there's
going to be a regency under prince
charles anytime soon and that is why
charles today not in the ceremonial
robes he is not our monarch this does on
the other hand give us time to get used
to an idea of king charles but he will
not be sitting in that throne he will be
sitting alongside that state imperial
crown and he will be backed up by his
son and heir the duke of cambridge worth
pointing out that because of this
modification to the role of lord
chancellor and therefore these uh two um
councillors of state the queen's two
councillors estate stepping in that
actually they are the other two uh
councillors of state are of course
prince harry and prince andrew this can
only be done today if there are two
cancers of state uh according to the
letters patent so
given that i think more and more
frequently as the queen becomes older
she's going to rely on those around her
and rely on her counselor's estate um we
i think there may need to be a
discussion about who those remaining two
councillors of state are given the more
controversial uh place that andrew and
harry now occupy within the family and
in the institution
tessa thanks very much just as we're
talking to you there we're seeing
another procession of cars uh going down
the mall there uh david so do you think
that this recession will be the ones
carrying the duke of cambridge prince
william do you know yes um
unless we've missed uh mr procession but
that that that was what was on the
program for which i was forewarned that
the second procession would be
um
with the cars with prince william the
duke of cambridge
uh and this route that they take down
the mall uh through horse guards uh then
onto whitehall
meticulously planned and rehearsed and
for those members of the military
involved in today it's it's a massive
event for them isn't it it is but i
think uh there are two important things
to to mention in connection with the
military involvement today and that is
the completely down scaling there would
normally be four or five times the
number of troops involved in this and if
it was a full ceremonial state opening
of parliament and you'll notice that
there are no horse-drawn carriages
for a start although that's of course
the royal household but accompanying uh
the carriages are normally um the
mounted regiment and you can see there
on your screens they're formed up
in a guard on horse guards parade but
normally they would they would accompany
and have previously accompanied the cars
as as well as carriages before so that
has been scaled down the result there
are also far fewer troops um street
lining um it's there are always
policemen there um street lining for
security purposes but for ceremonial and
and pageantry purposes
the armed forces including the navy and
the air force um have been streetlining
before and if you look carefully at the
pictures you'll see that there aren't
any
street liners
until you get to the house of lords
where the guard formed by the coal
stream guards
are posted outside with their band
our political editor beth rigby is in
the studio with me now and
beth
what is the prime minister trying to
achieve today what what for him would be
a good result today
well i think um in terms of the measures
uh what we're going to see is some
attempts for him to sort of reset his
premiership after a torrid few months so
there will be a leveling up and
regeneration bill that's expected to
give local leaders powers to rejuvenate
the high streets forcing landlords
to rent out empty shops more cheaply
which when i go up and down the country
people really upset actually about uh
their empty uh town centers he'll hope
that that will appear appeal to some of
those red wall areas that have uh
suffered a bit in terms in recent years
in terms of regeneration uh there will
be other things such as a bill to target
protesters the um extinction rebellion
protesters there will be something on
that there's going to be 38 different
bills uh seven measures of those will be
about scrapping eu regulation but if we
zoom out and say what politically is he
trying to do
i went back and had a look at the
queen's speech in 2019 shortly after he
won that majority in a queen's speech
really of course it's about policy for
the government but it's all about prime
minister prime ministerial power as well
and in 2019 after that uh massive
majority that big election win at the
height of his powers i think today what
we're seeing in this queen's speech is a
prime minister that might still have a
majority but he doesn't really have the
authority with his party anymore and
actually what's interesting about this
queen's speech as much as what's in it
is what's been left out
beth we're just uh looking at the duke
of cambridge i think arriving
at the sovereigns entrance
yes this will be the duke of cambridge
and
some people may be surprised that he is
not wearing uniform because um he is the
kernel of a regiment and
a number of regiments i think and so he
could be wearing ceremonial uniform but
his role today and this has been pointed
out as very much as a supporter
um
and i think we will see by contrast
prince charles will arrive in in full
admiral the fleet uniform
rhiannon mills our royal correspondent
also joins us now
rhiannon how did the royal family feel
about the fact that they are now all
doing greater duties
they all seem to be stepping into the
breach as it were
whenever i've spoken to members of the
royal family and they talk about those
big moments the big milestone moments
the big celebrations and the ceremonial
occasions they've always talked to me
about how
they have been the supporting cast for
the queen and that continues to be the
case but also there is this
appreciation i think from all of them
that
she has been remarkable she is now 96
years old and throughout her reign she
has continued to carry out her duties
but now increasingly she is having
mobility problems and
and so they are having to to step up and
i suspect step up
more quickly than they anticipated i
think for us it has been a surprise to
see that the queen has been unable to
attend
um
such a number of events over the last
seven months or so and and also i think
you get the sense from the palace as
well they're having to adjust to the
fact that that now it's expected that
younger members of the royal family are
being expected to do more but i think as
has always been the case for the queen
and also the duke of edinburgh when he
was alive it was all about preparing
children and grandchildren for the
responsibilities that lie ahead and
today as we saw the duke of cambridge
entering
the palace of westminster this is going
to be the first time that he's going to
to witness in person a state opening of
parliament of course prince charles and
the duchess of cornwall have been
alongside the monarch for a number of
occasions now so it's certainly not a
first for for prince charles in that
sense but it is going to be the first
time that he will he will sit and he
will read
the speech on on the queen's behalf it's
interesting what you were saying about
prince william being framed as very much
a supporter on this occasion that's
certainly not the messaging that we've
been hearing from buckingham palace
since it was announced that the queen
had authorized this letter's patent uh
in order to allow her two councillors of
state to carry out this important
ceremonial role the palace very clearly
saying last night that they are jointly
opening parliament today prince charles
and prince william yes prince charles
will read the speech but in a way they
are on an equal footing and i think that
is to try and play down any suggestions
that we'll hear today that we are
looking at a regency in action a prince
regent situation and also the palace
making it clear that this is one
occasion this is one authorization of a
handing over of responsibilities this is
not delegating other uh important roles
that the queen continues to carry out
and rhiannon we're just hearing that
from the press association that the
queen is understood to be watching the
proceedings on television from windsor
castle i don't know if she's watching
sky um but she will have her weekly
audience with the prime minister boris
johnson afterwards on wednesday so uh
she is still continuing to to carry out
with the rest of her duties uh and
keeping an eye
on what prince charles and prince
william are up to at the same time uh
lieutenant david leahy former black rod
uh is still with us
so so what happens now that
print uh prince william has arrived
prince charles will arrive very very
shortly they go in through the sovereign
entrance and then what happens so they
going through the sovereign's entrance
and um
go up through the the ceremonial
staircase the ground staircase to the
roping room and traditionally the roping
room is where the
royal
party assemble uh before they take part
in the state procession from the robbing
room through the royal gallery the royal
gallery is 40 50 yards long
and spectacular room
and we will see the procession
um go through the royal gallery into
princess chamber and from prince's
chamber into the house of lords but it's
in the roping room that um
normally the queen
um
has puts on her state robes and the
imperial state crown that that it is
literally the raving room it's not a
misnomer in any sense at all
um
and um and previously in the past that
would take a few minutes and she would
attend to
last minutes of
making sure that everything was in place
properly and then when she is ready
and usually
very much on time and punctually the
state trumpeters um
uh sound um um
a fantastic fanfare royal fanfare and
the doors of the royal the robbing room
open and we'll see that happening and
the the royal
party emerged from the roping room and
joined the state procession through the
royal gallery and we'll see that today
we're just gonna pause because that
there is uh some music coming
from outside sovereign's entrance
[Music]
the state
trumpeters um sounding a royal fanfare
and at the same time and i hope the
camera will show us on the top of the
victoria tower
uh the standard on the top of the uh
the royal standard will now be flying
from the top of the victoria tower so
the union jack is is lowered and the
royal standard is unfurled
and that represents the fact that the
crown is present in the palace of
westminster and the crown refers
literally to the crown to the crown but
not the monarch that may be wearing it
and that is the significance of the
crown the imperial state crown is the
symbolism of the crown
not the person
david thanks very much uh let's bring
back in uh sky news former political
editor and presenter adam bolton um adam
we've had the the local elections in the
last week
the conservatives obviously didn't do
quite as well as they might have liked
has that removed perhaps some of the
sheen from this queen's speech for boris
johnson
i think it has
we're told that the prime minister's new
team of advisors have slimmed down the
amount of legislation and they backed
off
from things which might be likely to
annoy some of their constituency for
example regulation of business auditing
that has
been removed from the government's
legislative plan and they do want
to appeal uh and to win back to a
certain extent uh those people uh who
deserted them
now uh what we're also seeing of course
is some pretty contentious areas because
there is going to be uh regulation of uh
online media digital media in this bill
and that of course uh is an area where
the government uh has to proceed very
carefully not least because uh this is
we're talking about an international uh
communications network how far can they
go and how successful can they be in
enforcing uh what they do so i think uh
what we're going to see this afternoon
is the uh prime minister and the leader
of the opposition uh what probably uh
ironing each other across the chamber
pretty uh
well with the
degree of distaste i suspect uh given uh
all the uh breakthroughs that have been
about what would happen if uh sakia
stamina is fine and what the
consequences might be in the long run
for boris johnson so they'll be
sensitive there and then of course
there's another area where boris johnson
can't avoid talking about that is the
cost of living crisis
but it's pretty clear looking at the
sort of
draft bills that have been postponed
that the government
have been talked about that the
government is going to say it is doing
everything it can
without really
promising radical changes
in the financial system or large sums
of
support going to those people who really
need them so that i think is a very
delicate balance
for
mr johnson who will see shortly
arriving at the bar of the house of
lords to listen to the speech i was just
wondering incidentally about the
language because of course it's not yet
prince charles's government but i think
in the queen speech he will still refer
to it as my government because he's uh
speaking on behalf
of the sovereign
let's bring in our current political
editor beth rigby who's sitting next to
me here in the studio
and beth it's been an interesting 24
hours in politics hasn't it and we we
heard from kierstama yesterday we are
going to hear from both the prime
minister and kia stammer later on today
aren't we in in the house of commons do
you think that that they will uh not
divert from the script that this it will
all be about the queen's speech or do
you expect the other issues that that
have
a lot of us have been focused on over
the past few days will creep in
well it will be the first time that they
meet since um
kierstama was it was announced that he
was under police investigation but as we
saw yesterday
kierstarma took
a gamble you could call it a calculated
gamble in which he sought to try and put
clear blue water between him and boris
johnson
by saying yes i'm under investigation if
i get a fixed penalty notice i will step
down as labour leader with all the
consequences of that uh that would
follow
and in that sense labour think that they
have put boris johnson in quite an
awkward position once more on this
because obviously he didn't resign when
he had a fixed penalty notice so i
imagine that both men white might want
to avoid that conversation whilst
discussing the queen's speech today you
have to put it in the context of the
queen not being there that this is quite
a
big moment it's obviously a regretful
moment that she can't attend and some of
my white horse sources were telling me
um that this decision was taken
genuinely right at the last minute that
it was not taken lightly
that she left it right to the final
point to finally sign uh that rit
authorizing her son
prince charles
to make that speech and it's quite a sad
day really that she isn't there and i'm
very glad to hear that she's going to be
watching it even if she can't be with us
but just quickly picking up on what adam
said about the politics of the queen's
speech i think one of the big themes
we're going to see today when i was
saying about things being left out is
part of this is about stripping to quote
some of the conservatives advisers that
helped both
david cameron and boris johnson in the
2015 and 19 elections is to strip the
barnacles off the boat and what that
means is taking out pieces of
legislation that might be controversial
with the conservative parliamentary
party in order to not give boris johnson
any more problems than he's already got
so in terms of a big planning bill
that's not there anymore in terms of
banning uh fur imports and foie gras
imports which was around animal cruelty
something the prime minister was looking
at that has been shelved plans to
give uh flexible work for that to be
written into law again with the
conservative right not very popular that
has been shelved and what you do see is
some brexit deregulation you see some
tougher measures on ex being able to
deport serious criminals so actually
this this queen's speech is very
political and it's as much about boris
johnson's survival at the moment as it
is about looking forward to the next
general election and i think that is
absolutely fascinating given that he's
got a big majority he's not actually
very politically powerful at the moment
it's about appeasing back benches
brilliant thanks beth thanks very much
um david leakey former black rod still
with us also we're seeing now uh the
commons aren't we on the right hand side
of our screen there just just talk us
through what's happening there so we've
got prince charles and prince william
arrived at the sovereign entrance being
robbed up if they were the queen but
what's happening on the other side so
well now we have a picture of the house
of commons chamber itself
mps assembling in the chamber uh over
the next five or ten minutes the chamber
normally would feel uh filled to brim
full
um and standing room and in fact not
even standing room um and then the house
of commons
um will start their mornings procedure
with the normal procedure the speaker's
procession from this down the library
corridor um uh through central lobby
this is central lobby here that's what
these people are gathered to and
mr speaker sir lindsay hoyle will will
process with his chaplain and his staff
through
central lobby down to the house commons
chamber
they will enter the chamber the doors
will then close whilst they start their
business which always starts with
prayers at the beginning of the day
and and what and the doors close
why why are the doors closed on black
rod
the doors are closed just for their
prayers after prayers
then they um suspend proceedings and the
doors are then reopened
um
and
once
uh the queen or in this case um prince
charles
has taken his place
on in the house of lords chamber not on
the throne but to one side of the throne
uh he will then give a signal and a
command to the lord great chamberlain
and we hear now as on the on the
speaker's ceremony um sir lindsay hoyle
with um
the speaker's chaplain and his
entourage
this is a formal procession that takes
place every day at the beginning of
proceedings
um in the house of commons
and similarly uh
the house of lords uh has a a similar
but actually rather smaller uh
procession that starts their proceedings
as well
what are they shouting hats off and this
is a sign of respect it's rather like
the military saluting a senior person
it's hats off when
so there you see the sergeant-at-arms
carrying the house of commons
mace
proceedings can't start in the house of
commons until the mace is on the table
so lindsey hoyle
the speaker's chaplain there and the
speaker's private secretary
[Music]
you'll notice the um
there was a steady cam following the
speaker
and i can remember the very first time i
was sent by the queen to
summon the mps from the house of commons
chamber
and
i i was surprised when
i noticed that
from the previous recordings which i i
had a look at that there was always a
rather close close-up of the black rod's
face as
uh he my predecessors had had walked
down towards the house of commons
chamber and
i then discovered that uh on the day
uh the reason they get that close up or
the way they get
is that there's a cameraman with a
steadicam who walks backwards in front
of you if that's not counterintuitive
and there's someone behind him who's
reeling in a wire
so you have to actually walk quite
slowly and try and keep a straight face
and not bump into him and not bump into
him i'll trip over him and we just saw
the camera going to black there that's
for the prayers and is that what the
bell signifies and that's what the bells
so that signifies that the house of
commons um chamber has is now in session
the mace is on the table the speaker is
in the chair and prayers will commence
and we're focusing on this you know it
this is all
tradition isn't it but it's also part of
the law of parliament that this the
structure of this event and the fact
that the queen opens and closes it
yes and and the
the background to this is that there are
three elements to our legislative
constitution
um
our constitutional legislature put the
other way around and the three elements
are the house of commons the
democratically elected chamber
and the house of lords which is often
called the advising or advisory or
revising chamber
and then the sovereign who signs off or
enacts uh legislation and those are the
three constant and
constitutional elements of the
legislature and it's on this day the
state opening of parliament that all
those three elements come together in
one place at one time
and
it's also significant that the palace of
westminster and used to be a royal
palace exclusively owned by the
sovereign in fact henry viii it was his
residence he was the last sovereign to
live there um but it's been under the it
was under the ownership of the sovereign
until as recently as 1965 and it was
only in 1965 that the queen and it was
on her initiative and
agreed with harold wilson who was the
prime minister at the time that it was
inappropriate for the sovereign to own
the democratically elected chamber of
parliament
and and and so
they agreed that the
uh the house of lords and the house of
commons parts of the palace of
westminster would be handed over from
the sovereign and taken under the
management and control of the house of
lords and house of commons and that was
done in a statement on the ch in on the
floors of the chamber and but
interestingly the sovereign has retained
some parts of the palace of westminster
so it is in part still a royal palace
you kept kept the sovereign's entrance
entrance and the royal robing room and
the royal gallery and westminster hall
too and just remind us how
how it was affected by covid the queen's
speech how different was it over the
last couple of years
well it was very much a dress down or
scaled down kovid and
everybody present was wearing was
wearing masks
and it was a very much
a very much less ceremonial occasion
with minimal contact and
and smaller attendance as well
let's bring back in tessa dunlop the
royal historian and author and
tessa one wonders what's going through
prince charles and prince william's
minds today prince charles obviously
knows that this potentially on the
passing of his mother is his destiny
isn't it but today just standing in for
her
yeah he's had a lifetime of training we
know that recently he's been there at
the state opening of parliament very
much in a supportive role um and in many
respects i think what we see here is the
monarchy not as an individual but as an
institution and charles there he is in
his admiral of the fleet uniform you
know surrounded by regalia and structure
form history pomp and ceremony and it
seems less about him as the individual
and rather about him as part of this
regal institution
that is an extraordinary sort of
umbrella
over our form of government in britain
and i'm sure that the queen watching
today will feel
a lot of maternal pride because her
son's been on something of a journey
over the last few decades and actually
um it's it i think it's a sort of
comfort almost to see him surrounded by
this structure of state and and of
royalty it sort of almost reduces the
pressure on him it reminds us that it's
not about individual personalities
monarchy
much less so and in some respects it's
just about them sort of uh providing us
with this sovereign canopy if you like
and i think he'll do it very well i'm
sure he's rehearsed the speech a few
times in front of the mirror this
morning incidentally when both the
queen's father and grandfather were ill
and the lord chancellor stood in for
them on both occasions their illness was
referred to before the queen's speech or
rather that the king's speech at that
time was was commenced
so so it is we think it's possible that
she she may well be mentioned before
this speech actually starts
it has been historically the case that
former ill monarchs um their um
disposition has been referred to
okay and just incidentally i've worked
with a lot of women who served actually
in the same military service as the
queen during the war and i quite often
do public events with those women and i
invariably always book two or three
because when you are over 95 actually
you can't guarantee your presence
tessa thanks very much we're just seeing
uh the crown arriving in the house of
lords a former back black rod david
leakey is here um so prince charles
sitting uh
on what looks very grand but we tell
that he wouldn't sit on the actual
throne is that a different throne to the
one that the queen used there are in
fact two thrones and
there is the the the sovereign's throne
and the consorts throne and it uh may
well be that he is sitting on the
console's throne
hard to tell the difference at this
range yeah and we see you will see there
the lord the lord great chamberlain on
the right of your picture with the white
stave or staff has just raised it in the
air that is the signal for black rod
to
process
and there it goes she goes she goes
sarah clark
tell us about black rod at the moment
so sarah clark who took over from me
four years ago uh in in the role and
formerly she was the
um director of operations at the
wimbledon tennis championships uh that
was part of her background
and
you can now hear the door being slammed
see it being stand there
it's black rod
open the door
[Music]
mr speaker the queen commands this
honorable house
to attend her councillors of state
immediately in the house of peers
so the black rod has delivered the
command for mps to attend
um
the the state councillors
and
the mps now traditionally will take
their time and they will
and they will not process to the house
of lords they will proceed there in a
rabble and normally a talkative and
babbling rabble too and this is part of
the
house of commons display of i wouldn't
go so far as to say disrespect
but
for the crown but as part of the theater
of their independence their political
independence of the crown
and uh you will normally see that they
they're quite uh noisy when they arrive
in the house of lords chamber they
continue to talk even when they're uh at
the bar of the house of lords chamber um
even when the queen was sitting on the
throne there'd still be quite a lot of a
hum of conversation and uh normally the
queen with just a glance over her eyes
would silence the silence the mps um
normally helped by
occasionally i remember having to turn
around slightly from the front of the
bar
turning around to the mps and
i remember
one prime minister saying
we're getting the bdi from black rod and
there was then
quiet that's best one this is what one
of one of my favorite things about this
event is is this part that we see all
the mps coming out together
you see the leader in the leader of the
opposition together
uh all smiles
sometimes not i mean this is so you know
this is one of my favorite bits because
when we make the television package for
the evening news we sort of sit there
and
study the body language between the
prime minister and the leader of the
opposition try and work out what they're
all saying to you well and i remember
with jeremy corbyn one year
that boris johnson sort of looked to him
and tried to make conversation and
jeremy corbyn just was not having it and
just refused to engage and boris johnson
kind of looked around a bit awkwardly
and i wonder what will be the dynamic
when we look back at this between um
kierstama and boris johnson because it's
got quite personal between them although
they look to me like they were smiling a
bit between each other we just saw them
coming out of the comments but i have to
admit as a political watch it's one of
my favorite things to check out i have
to say and they're already arriving in
the house of lords it's not very far
away is it best it's it's no it's not
too far
and and seeing the strange political bed
fellows that were next to each other
from other parts of the party
interesting what's happening here now so
this is the lord chancellor uh is
delivering the queen's speech to uh
prince charles and that is
dominic robb secretary of state for
justice
um who carries the other title the state
title of uh lord jesus my lord lord
heights and members of the house of
commons
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
her majesty's government will level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work
our majesty's ministers will continue to
support the police
to make the streets safer
and fund the national health service
to reduce the kobe backlogs
in these challenging times
her majesty's government
will play a leading role
in defending democracy and freedom
across the world
including continuing to support the
people of ukraine
her majesty's government will drive
economic growth
to improve living standards
and fund sustainable investment
in public services
this will be underpinned by a
responsible approach
to the public finances
reducing debt while reforming and
cutting taxes
her majesty's ministers
will support the bank of england to
return inflation to its target
a bill will be brought forward
to drive local growth
empowering local leaders
to regenerate their areas
and ensuring everyone can share in the
united kingdom's success
the planning system will be reformed
to give residents more involvement in
local development
her majesty's government will improve
transport across the united kingdom
delivering safer
cleaner
services
and enabling more innovations
legislation will be introduced
to modernize rail services
and improve reliability for passengers
i manage these ministers will bring
forward
an energy bill to deliver the transition
to cheaper cleaner and more secure
energy
this will build on the success of the
cop26 summit
in glasgow last year
draft legislation
to promote competition
strengthen consumer rights
and protect households and businesses
will be published
measures will also be published to
create new competition rules
for digital markets
and the largest digital firms
her majesty's government will establish
the uk infrastructure bank
in legislation
with objectives to support economic
growth
and the delivery of net zero
reforms to education
will help every child fulfill their
potential
wherever they live
raising standards and improving the
quality of schools
and higher education
her majesty's ministers will publish
draft
legislation
to reform the mental health act
her majesty's government will continue
to seize the opportunities
of the united kingdom's departure from
the european union
to support economic growth
regulations on businesses will be
repealed and reformed
a bill will enable law inherited from
the european union
to be more easily amended
sector procurement
will be simplified
to provide new opportunities for small
businesses
new legislation will strengthen the
united kingdom's
financial services industry
ensuring that he continues to act in the
interest of all people and communities
the united kingdom's data protection
regime
will be reformed
her majesty's government will continue
to champion international trade
delivering jobs across the country
and growing the economy
legislation will be introduced
to enable the implementation
of the united kingdom's first new
free trade agreements since leaving the
european union
her majesty's ministers
will encourage agricultural and
scientific innovation at home
legislation will unlock the potential of
new technologies
to promote sustainable and efficient
farming and food production
her majesty's government
will protect the integrity of the united
kingdom's borders
and ensure the safety of its people
her majesty's ministers will take action
to prevent dangerous and illegal channel
crossings
and tackle the criminal gangs who profit
from facilitating them
legislation will be introduced
to ensure the police have the powers to
make the streets safer
a bill will be brought forward to
further strengthen powers to tackle
illicit finance
reduce economic crime
and help businesses grow
measures will be introduced to support
the security services and help them
protect the united kingdom
her majesty's government will lead the
way
in championing security around the world
it will continue to invest in her
majesty's gallant armed
forces her majesty's ministers will work
closely with international partners
to maintain a united nato
and address the most pressing global
security challenges
the continued success
and integrity of the whole of the united
kingdom is of paramount importance to
her majesty's government
including the internal economic bonds
between all of its parts
her majesty's government will prioritize
support
for the belfast good friday agreement
and its institutions
including through legislation to address
the legacy of the past
her majesty's government will ensure the
constitution is defended
her majesty's ministers will restore the
balance of power
between the legislature and the courts
by introducing a bill of rights
legislation will prevent public bodies
engaging in boycotts
that undermine community cohesion
her majesty's government will introduce
legislation
to improve the regulation of social
housing
to strengthen the rights of tenants
and ensure better quality safer homes
legislation will also be introduced to
ban conversion therapy
proposals will be published to establish
an independent regulator of english
football
in this year of the platinum jubilee
her majesty looks forward to the
celebrations
taking place across the united kingdom
and throughout the commonwealth
and to the commonwealth games in
birmingham this summer
members of the house of commons
estimates for the public services will
be laid before you
my lords and members of the house of
commons
other measures will be laid before you
her majesty prays that the blessing of
almighty god
may rest upon your councils
and that there the queen's speech read
by prince charles you can see prince
william on the left there of the duchess
of cornwall in front
and the crown now being removed from the
house of lords
and the crown and the royal regalia
leaving the chamber
along with prince charles prince william
and those journeys will now be made in
reverse
let's bring in our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills um
rhiannon
no mention made of the queen at the
start of the speech but but referred to
the fact that she's very much looking
forward to her royal jubilee by prince
charles in that note
that's right there was no
reference to the fact that she was
unable to attend in person due to those
mobility issues
but interestingly within that speech
rather than talking about my government
the words had been changed to say her
majesty's government so
still mentioned there
in the chamber and for me this felt like
a very striking
defining moment for the monarchy for 70
years the state opening of parliament
and delivering
the queen's speech has punctuated the
queen's record-breaking reign of course
this year as was mentioned in that
speech she marks her platinum jubilee
the first british monarch ever to
achieve
that milestone and this was the first
time that another member of her family
has delivered that speech on her behalf
the two previous occasions where she was
unable to attend because she was
pregnant the speech was delivered by the
lord chancellor that role has changed a
great deal and so her majesty
in consultation with other authorities
decided that the responsibility today
for the first time should fall
to her heir to the prince of wales and
in many ways
within that historic setting amongst all
of the traditional ceremony that we have
seen
throughout the decades
this was also giving us a glimpse at the
future of course
prince charles is her heir and one day
will be king and this again was another
step
towards that role another moment in his
learning another moment in the
apprenticeship as air which has
continued for for so many years for him
and also i think particularly important
the fact that the duke of cambridge was
also there in the chamber the first time
that he has witnessed for himself
the state opening of parliament
and everything that the palace has been
saying yes
if you look at the imagery it looks like
the prince that prince william was there
as a support to the prince of wales but
i think for the palace they have wanted
to stress that
son and grandson were today jointly
carrying out that responsibility
of opening parliament yes the queen
today was unable to attend herself but
for her she was so conscious that the
monarchy still had that vital role to
perform
to allow that new parliamentary session
to finally begin
thanks very much
uh let's return to our political editor
beth rigby uh beg beth away from from
the royal implications of what we've
seen we're now watching all the mps
filed back into
at the house of commons they will now
break now won't they and then they'll
return this afternoon just after two
where they'll start discussing the
queen's speech
what do you think was the key thing that
we heard from it well you're right
there's going to be a number of days of
debate on it i mean the first thing that
struck was it was quite short
this is a slimmed down queen speech
really if you boil it down what's in it
i think there's two elements of it one
is leveling up and you saw that you can
see it the introduction from the prime
minister on the speech as well was where
he
stresses that this is a queen's speech
to get our country back on track and
ensure we deliver on the promises we
made at the start of the parliament none
bigger than leveling up the country and
you had a schools bill in there
promising to reform education you had
that leveling up and regeneration bill
promising to try and uh sort out and
improve people's uh high streets but
then on the other side of it jane there
was loads of red meat in here
for the conservative party and those uh
those brexiteers and those others
towards the right of the party that
really got boris johnson into number 10
and perhaps at the moment might be
having second thoughts about him there
was loads of deregulation in there
promises on procurement bills there's a
brexit freedom bill
talking about uh repealing and reforming
some legislation
which they will say help unleash and
deregulate the british economy to get it
uh growing there was a public order bill
to clamp down on that extinction
rebellion
and people uh that
they have said being too disruptive
um
there was uh but but also what was left
out i think as i was saying earlier is
also interesting uh there was no uh
writing into law uh enshrining into law
the right to flexible working which
obviously is a big issue now over over
covered and people wanting more hybrid
uh working arrangements and there was as
i was saying earlier any attempts to try
and uh regulate in terms of
banning fur imports or foie gras imports
that was all canned as well it was it is
was as i say in a kind of attempt to
scrape the barnacles off the boat so
focus on things that are wedge issues
that the conservatives would say which
which uh split them from the lib dems
and labour focus on on sort of the core
johnson agenda look jane what what are
they going to talk about in the commons
from labour's point of view it's all
about the cost of living and i think
that's what kierstarm is going to go in
on and i think he's also going to start
raising the issue the prospect of
stagflation and that's when you have
very in high inflation and economic
growth
slows it's very bad for an economy and
it's very very bad for people because
they feel the squeeze so tightly
everything's going up in cost their
wages are not growing we know what is
coming down the tracks in terms of
potential recession and very very high
inflation and i think that for all of
this queen's speech labour understand
that the immediate pressure will be this
uh kit malthouse was asked this morning
on sky news whether there might be an
emergency budget he didn't explicitly
rule it out and i think that for all of
the
legislation in the queen's speech that
is going to be the massive challenge
for boris johnson's government uh and
and the huge focus for all of us in the
coming months
beth we're just seeing prince charles
leave you can spot if you're eagle-eyed
alastair bruce royal commentator just in
the back uh left-hand side of the shop
there we're going to be talking to him
uh in a short while about his experience
today what it's like being so so close
to what is happening there uh so we're
seeing now prince charles departing the
house of lords the crown and the royal
regalia have already left
prince william will be departing quite
soon
let's return to adam bolton who's down
on college green for us and anna beth
was talking about some of the things
that weren't in the queen's speech and
one of the things uh
that a lot of people especially northern
ireland were hoping there would be would
be some bill about protecting the good
friday agreement that wasn't in there
was it
yes but on the other hand nor was
explicit uh legislation to deal with the
northern ireland protocol so i think
what we're seeing is the government uh
proceeding very cautiously uh here uh
and the prime minister has said in the
house of commons as you know that he
regards saving the good friday agreement
as uh the priority in the current
situation of trying to deal with the
problems uh of the protocol so i think
that is probably one of those areas
where
we can see the government taking a step
back from taking perhaps uh the most
proactive
action aggressive action uh confronting
uh the european union uh but it's
interesting uh
released along with the text of the
queen's speech
is an introduction from the prime
minister
and
i think it's probably a foretaste of
what we're going to hear from him in the
house of commons
first thing he talks about is ukraine
saying that britain has led the way
responding to uh putin's brutal attack
then he talks about covid
again saying that in his view the
government has led the way protecting
lives and livelihoods
then he moves on to the economy and the
cost of living crisis but what's
interesting there
is he says
it is right that we continue doing
whatever we can to ease the burdens on
people
people are grappling with now
and that of course i think is is going
to be as beth was saying
the main issue of debate whether the
government is doing enough for uh the
less well-off who are now being hit by
this cost of living crisis and
particularly
high energy levels so i think um
it's a queen speech you know it's a
workmanlike job uh stressing things like
legislate uh cutting
eu base red tape and also talking about
leveling up but the substance even the
way the prime minister is presenting it
in his forward
suggests uh that he knows there's quite
a lot of ground
that needs to be made up uh interesting
too seeing this kind of mixed ceremony
with
prince charles and the cars rather than
carriages conveying the royal family i
have to say at the same time
the security around westminster is
greater than i've ever seen
in four decades of these queen speeches
they've sealed off all the way around
the palace uh and the marlins and
james's park as well as here in
westminster and uh you know it's
important to remember that this used to
be a public event we used to have
spectators standing here on the green
watching uh the queen arriving and all
that but now
for security reasons i suppose we
haven't seen
seen that but we've had no explanation
from the police of why uh there is much
greater uh security
than we've had in previous years perhaps
there is a significant terrorist threat
but it's quite striking how
difficult uh albeit a slim down ceremony
is making it for people here in central
london
adam as as we speak to you we're just
looking at the the raw crown being
loaded into a car actually i thought
they'd already left the building but no
uh the crown is now about to leave and
of course the royal regalia as well also
leaving there what what your instincts
adam uh is going to be the front page
tomorrow what do you think the the
tabloids are going to go with from this
queen speech
i think the story is going to be that it
wasn't the queen's speech
that it was her majesty's government
speech uh the story is i think for the
general public is the
clear spectacle of
prince charles uh rather you know did
rather well reading uh the queen's
speech rather than the queen being there
talking about her in the
in in the third person her majesty's
government and of course you know when
uh there is a transition in the monarchy
it will be the king's speech it will be
prince charles's speech but i thought in
the way that he delivered it the way
that he repeatedly substituted her
majesty's her majesty for the word my
was him you know wanting to give as much
support and presence
to his mother as he possibly could but i
think that will be the story that people
will remember beyond that i think the
various newspapers according to their
political predilections will seize on
various things a lot of concern for
example on the left in the guardian and
the
daily mirror perhaps about potential
threats to civil rights coming in in
this clampdown on protesters
and then in the more conservative
newspapers the uh
daily mail and the telegraph uh they
will doubtless be cheered by uh some of
the
attacks that promises to cut red tape
and promises to find benefits uh from
brexit
and also
by some of the law and order measures
because in the in the way that they've
divided up the speech
uh for presentation uh there is a strong
section uh on uh what they're calling uh
not so much law and order they're
calling it making the streets safer the
the sort of headlines which they've
given to the speech growing the economy
to address the cost of living
well we talked about that
making the streets safer
funding the nhs to clear the code bad
glock again you know that's not actually
promising more money and
it's still trying to look at the
problems of social care a draft bill on
mental health
and then
finally providing leadership needed in
challenging times well one has to say
that is
the boilerplate
very often of every government when it
hasn't got a great deal to advertise
adam thanks very much for that
let's return to our political editor
beth brigby uh with me in the studio
here beth what from your mind was the
key thing from that speech adam adam
felt the headline would be that it
wasn't delivered by the queen what do
you think the papers will go with
tomorrow well i think i think adam's
absolutely spot on i mean from a public
point of view let's just i mean the
queen it's her due it's her platinum
jubilee year and she's not there to
deliver the speech she's watching it um
[Music]
on television from home because of those
mobility issues not able
to do that in person for the first time
in 59 years
that's really what the public care about
today isn't it how is the queen how is
she doing
um
and it was hugely symbolic wasn't it
that her her son and her grandson were
there in her stead to represent her so i
think in terms of the public consumption
in terms of what people will be
interested in it will be that i think
but in terms of the politics of it as i
was saying i think there's two things
going on here boris johnson wants to
signal to the public that his government
is back on track he wants to level up
the country he wants to give people
more help but he's also
lost the authority within his party
after all of the scandals and the torrid
time he's had in recent months and in
terms of what he's trying to do
for the final two years of his
administration
he has shaved a lot of the barnacles off
the boat he's trying to avoid
controversial legislation because he
doesn't need another fight
with his mps but i think it's also
important jane just one other thing to
sort of zoom out a bit and remember what
happened last week in those local
elections because
yes uh kierstarma didn't have a stonking
knight in the way that would have
propelled him uh to being on track to a
majority government
uh in 2024
but he did do well enough and the
conservatives did badly enough that on
the projections that sky news and others
made in terms of voting attention if you
strap later out it's difficult because
local elections uh people there's lower
turnout people might vote on different
issues local issues protest votes but
nevertheless boris johnson was well
short of a majority on those projections
278
seats now he can't necessarily find a
coalition partner will the lib dems want
to go back into power with boris johnson
the dup and the conservatives are
certainly
fallen out badly so
over over northern ireland and the
brexit protocols and and so uh the
northern ireland protocol so basically
going out of those elections even though
the press focused on kierstama and that
police investigation if you're a
conservative mp you're thinking at the
moment boris johnson's heading
for a hung parliament being the largest
party and those 50 marginal mps could
lose their seats so he's got a huge
majority but he really is lacking
authority at the moment and that is an
interesting conundrum for him
overlay that with the cost of living
crisis labour are going to go really
hard today on stagflation that's when
you get high inflation sluggish economic
growth it frightens policymakers because
there's not that many monetary policy
tools that you can
you can use to try and alleviate that
and for all the obvious reasons it
frightens the government too because
people are then really struggling i mean
it's going to be a very very bumpy few
months and what kirstarma will hope to
do today beginning again today and
carrying on is capitalized on it but you
know i should say jane there is a risk
that he'll have to stand down
if you're just joining us you're
watching sky news it's just after midday
we are bringing you continuing coverage
of the queen's speech the speech has
been delivered by prince charles we're
now seeing uh the royal crown regalia
returning back to buckingham palace
we're also seeing prince charles and
prince william returning back as well
joined in the studio by our political
editor beth rigby just thinking about
what we heard in the speech and and beth
you you referred to kirsten possibly
having to stand down this was an
extraordinary gamble some would say that
he made yesterday in in stating that he
would stand down if he was given a fine
for an event that happened during the
the election campaign isn't it
yeah i mean there's different views is
it a calculated gambler is it just an
extraordinary gamble but the point is it
is a gamble now you could argue
that kierstama had very little option
and that is my analysis of it in that if
you set yourself up as a man of
principle and honor trying to
uh cast boris johnson as a man who has
neither if that's your position which is
what kierstama has been doing for months
you then have to fall on your sword if
you like i mean he would have lost all
credibility if he tried to equivocate on
this matter i don't think he had an
option and actually as i understand it i
think he took the decision on friday
actually
i think but i think kirstama
probably knew pretty
early on that this would be where
he would have to get to it obviously
took a weekend of lots of discussions
because different people around the
table would have different views um
and you know other people would argue
well look durham police have said that
retrospectively they won't issue fixed
penalty notices and that actually this
is a calculated gamble because the
chances are
that he won't be fine but he does not
know that for sure and you know rishi
sunak who turned up to that impromptu
birthday party in number 10 didn't think
he would be fine he was turning up to a
meeting there was a birthday celebration
for the prime minister he got a fixed
penalty notice so kierstama can't know
so of course it's a huge gamble and he's
literally going to have to resign if the
police give him a fixed penalty notice i
guess his calculation is that if he
survives that
uh then he really is standing on very
solid ground when he then criticizes the
prime minister and who knows jane his
allies would say maybe this gives him
the cut through with the public that so
far let's face it he has struggled to
get
okay beth thanks very much for now well
you're watching skye we are live in
westminster where in a defining moment
for the monarchy for the first time in
59 years the queen has missed the state
opening of parliament due to her health
her majesty's son prince charles
delivered the speech which included a
new crackdown on guerrilla-style climate
protests and tackling the cost of living
crisis the duke of cambridge also
attended for the first time on the
queen's behalf as councillor of state
let's take a look back at how the events
of the morning played out
our first sighting of prince charles was
as he left buckingham palace for
parliament
also in that motorcade was the duke of
cambridge and the duchess of cornwall as
well as the imperial state crown and the
ceremonial sword
it is the first time that the duke of
cambridge prince william has attended
the state opening of parliament and take
on a key constitutional role on behalf
of the queen he's deputising for her and
his role as a councillor of state as is
his father even though prince charles
read the speech out
it's black rod
open the door
a key moment there sarah clark who holds
the post of black rod striking the door
of the commons three times
black rod controls access to the chamber
and is the monarch's representative in
the lords
mps were then summoned for the queen's
speech
after the common store was slammed in
black rod's face that symbolized the
rights of parliament
well let's just listen in to some of
that speech
my lords and members of the house of
commons
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
her majesty's government will level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work
our majesty's ministers
will continue to support the police
to make the streets safer
and fund the national health service to
reduce the kovid backlogs
in these challenging times
her majesty's government
will play a leading role
in defending democracy
and freedom
across the world
including continuing to support the
people of ukraine
her majesty's government will drive
economic growth
to improve living standards
and fund sustainable investment
in public services
this will be underpinned
by a responsible approach
to the public finances
reducing debt while reforming
and cutting taxes
her majesty's government will continue
to seize the opportunities
of the united kingdom's departure from
the european union
to support economic growth
regulations on businesses will be
repealed and reformed
a bill will enable law inherited from
the european union
to be more easily
amended public sector procurement
will be simplified to provide new
opportunities for small businesses
new legislation will strengthen the
united kingdom's
financial services industry
ensuring that he continues to act in the
interest of all people
and communities
the united kingdom's data protection
regime
will be reformed
her majesty's government will continue
to champion international trade
delivering jobs across the country
and growing the economy
legislation will be introduced
to enable the implementation
of the united kingdom's first new
free trade agreements since leaving the
european union
in this year of the platinum jubilee
majesty looks forward to the
celebrations
taking place across the united kingdom
and throughout the commonwealth
and to the commonwealth games in
birmingham this summer
well rhiannon mills is outside
parliament for us right now and um
you could sort of see on prince
charles's face i think as he as he
delivered those lines actually
i i wonder if he wonders whether the
queen will be able to attend these
events she's clearly looking forward to
them but as we see the monarchy is
flexing and other people are coming in
to assist her
at the moment as her mobility falters
i think today was was again a reminder
of how over the years we have become so
used to her majesty the queen
carrying out her public services and
duties
and enjoying relatively good health and
yet now we have a monarch who herself
has admitted in recent weeks and months
that she is having
trouble standing and walking and
as a result of that the royal family the
palace and also the public are going to
have to get used to seeing younger
members of the royal family increasingly
stepping up and taking on some of her
responsibilities and i think yes we will
see that around the platinum jubilee
weekend but if we look at today it was a
hugely
symbolic moment and i think it will be
seen as one of those
defining moments for the monarchy when
historians look back at these twilight
years of this elizabethan age there has
been this softly softly approach to
transition and yes we have seen younger
members of the royal family already
stepping up and helping the queen things
like prince charles laying her wreath at
the cenotaph for remembrance sunday
other members of all family carrying out
investitures and also doing those
overseas tours on her behalf but today
was the first time that really we've
seen younger members of the family
taking on what is a key part of her
constitutional role and the decision for
that will not have been taken lightly
literally until the 11th hour we were
told that the queen herself wanted to
come she planned to come but as i think
we've seen in recent weeks when it's
come to things like the commonwealth day
service the maundy service
events where she would have to walk
great distances or sit for a long time
and this again would have been one of
them practicality has simply had to kick
in and that's what's happened
with this one and it was always going to
be interesting for constitutional
experts and the like likes of you and i
to see exactly how the queen wanted this
to play out and i think those
constitutional experts some of them were
puzzled and surprised by the fact that
she decided to use that letter's patent
so that
change in the rules
to mean that two councillors of state so
her son and grandson would carry out the
responsibilities today but that
ultimately is the way that she decided
it should be and we are seeing the
constitution flex and change
to deal with an aging monarch although
the palace very keen to point out that
this is not a monarch who is looking at
abdicating if you look at her accession
day speech that she made her accession
day message that she delivered
in february this year to start the
platinum jubilee year once again she
reaffirmed her commitment to serving her
country and the commonwealth but today
she has handed over
maybe just for this year we're going to
have to wait and see but that important
constitutional role of making sure that
the parliamentary session could still
get underway despite the fact that she
wasn't able to appear
here in person but yeah the palace very
clearly also saying that yes she's
having trouble with her ability but it
is still going to be the queen who will
have a virtual session with privy
council this week it's still going to be
the queen who is going to speak to her
prime minister and ultimately it was her
son and her grandson who were jointly
opening parliament today however i think
the problem is and for those who talk
about this being a regency a prince
regent situation and everything but name
the optics today seeing prince charles
front and center it did look more like a
regency situation
than i suspect the palace would
necessarily want to but
ultimately that was how the ceremony
played out and the palace stressing that
she is still very much in charge and
certainly when it comes to platinum
jubilee she will still be the star of
proceedings
okay rhiannon thank you very much
well let's move away uh from the queen's
non-attendance to the political meet of
this all beth rugby our political editor
is here and beth what do you think with
the the key bills that the government
wants to try to get through over the
next year
well i mean
the key bill and the one that was
was talked of first is that leveling up
and regeneration bill you know that
boris johnson has set his stall on
leveling up the country he's tasked
michael gove one of his most effective
political operations operators to try
and deliver on that and this a bill uh
in which the government says uh is aimed
at driving local growth empowering local
leaders to regenerate their areas
critically the interesting thing i
thought in it is this planning system to
be reformed to give residents more
involvement in local development now
you've got to ask does that mean that
big house building plans will be put on
pause because often in local communities
people don't want loads of development
and there was an attempt earlier in this
parliament this government we're going
to try and drive through what would be
quite controversial housing plans they
got a target 300 000 new homes a year
but that that maybe won't be happening
they pulled that specific
kind of policy and then now uh
what is happening with that it's again a
red line or it creates a red mist should
i say with many conservatives maybe
boris johnson doesn't want to have that
fight but in terms of other
efforts to regenerate high streets a
plan to ask or
compel landlords to give cheaper rents
in local high streets to try and
rejuvenate people's local areas because
the government understands that if you
make people's local environments better
that makes them feel better
and maybe that makes them feel that
their community is leveling up which of
course is the big promise of this
government so i think that that is
that's a critical one uh the other one
the public order bill again this is the
legislation to stop those channel
crossings
and also to ensure that the police have
more
powers
to make the streets safer they're also
looking at those that that security bill
in order to try and stop those
extinction rebellion protests so some
red meat again uh to conservatives but
also to the public who have been
disrupted
by uh
by that
by those um protests so there's all of
that in terms of for the politically for
the party
uh there's a deregulation effort in here
i was speaking to a cabinet minister
about it earlier about what the tenor of
this speech was saying it's very much
not
a
nanny state getting involved in
micromanaging people's lives and
policies i mean one policy which was to
try and tackle obesity was trying to
stop bog offs buy one get one free at
supermarkets that shelved uh the other
things i was talking about about
stopping banning imports of fur and foie
gras i mean for the tory right those
kind of infringements on what they would
see as people's freedoms uh they really
really don't like that and and one
cabinet minister said to me on the right
of the party the aim of this was to be
deregulatory supply-side reforms that's
how they want to try and tackle uh
inflation issues such as
bans on fur
against that and see marginal in issues
compared to the cost of living why spend
parliamentary time on that but of course
when it comes to the cost of living and
this risk of stagflation which is what
labor i think what kierstama is going to
raise in the commons you can't really
necessarily legislate for that you might
need to bring in an emergency budget now
so far the government have pushed back
on that really hard but with the cost of
living crisis intensifying with
inflation
rising
can they continue to hold off uh giving
people concrete support to the autumn
now rishi sinak the chancellor said he
wants to hold off because they don't
know yet how energy prices will move
but that doesn't help people right now
whose bills are going up
at uh astonishing and frightening rates
compared with their wages
and struggling to make ends meet if you
want to level up the country if people
cannot afford to feed their families or
heat their homes that that is really the
basics of people having or feeling that
they have a reasonable standard of
living isn't it it is beth thank you
very much
we're going to be bringing you a lot
more reaction to the queen's speech
we're going to be talking to all the
main political parties stay with sky
news but we're going to take a short
break
[Music]
on sky news we discuss and debate the
issues that affect us in a new lineup
for midweek programmes at 9pm join me
trevor phillips for common ground where
i bring two people together who hold
different opinions on current topics
seeing what might unite them i'm sophie
ridge join me for the take where we'll
be discussing the biggest political
stories of the week getting the opinions
from politicians and also our viewers
panel and join me for beth rigby
interviews as i question decision makers
from all walks of life exploring their
views on what's going on with britain
today join us midweek at nine on sky
news as we put people at the heart of
the stories
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're bothering firing together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's take you down to westminster now
so jeffrey donaldson who's the leader of
the dup uh mp and mla for the lagan
valley has been talking to sam coats
well
i left the prime minister with a very
clear message that
if the government is in the business of
protecting the political institutions
then they need to deal with the protocol
because the protocol is undermining
political stability in northern ireland
it is undermining our place within the
united kingdom
i welcome the references in the queen's
speech to protecting the internal
economic bonds
of all the parts of the united kingdom
and that has to include north island i i
note the reference to the
belfast or good friday agreement and
protecting the political institutions
and we are very clear the protocol is
incompatible with protecting the
economic bonds of all parts of the
united kingdom and it's incompatible
with the agreement so it needs to be
addressed and we are having further
discussions with the government about
that and i've made clear to the prime
minister there isn't a single unionist
representative elected to the assembly
supporting the protocol there is no
consensus for the protocol in northern
ireland
let's take a look at some of the day's
other news now and 75 days since russia
began its invasion of ukraine u.s
president joe biden says he's worried
that vladimir putin does not have a way
out of the war
speaking at a political fundraiser last
night the u.s president said the russian
leader mistakenly believed that the
conflict would destabilize nato and the
european union
ukraine's defense minister says that
russian forces backed by tanks and
artillery have attempted to storm the as
of style steel plants in mario paul the
last remaining pocket of ukrainian
forces have been holding out in
soviet-era tunnels beneath the complex
while ukraine's military claims one
person was killed and five were wounded
after
seven missiles hit a shopping center in
the southern city of odessa overnight
emergency services
were seen trying to extinguish the blaze
engulfing the structure while trying to
find any sign of life
in the charred wreckage
let's take you to the philippines now
where ferdinand marcos jr has been
elected as the new president of the
philippines he's the son of the
country's former dictator and received
almost twice as many votes as his
nearest rifle the marcos family were
forced into exile in 1986 the campaign
to elect marcos jr also known as
bongbong portrayed the rule of his
father as a golden era for the nation
the met office says there is now a 50 50
chance the world will warm by more than
1.5 degrees celsius over the next five
years
compared with pre-industrial levels 1.5
degrees is the goal set by nations in
2015 as part of the paris agreement to
try to limit global warming researchers
say that carbon dioxide emissions
reached the highest level ever recorded
last year
the podcaster deborah james has been
moved to hospice at home care to treat
her terminal bowel cancer after telling
followers she does not know how long she
has left
forty-year-old james was diagnosed with
the condition in 2016 she presented the
bbc podcast you me and the big c and has
kept listeners and social media
followers up to date with her treatments
with candid posts about her progress
and diagnosis
a car has crashed into the house owned
by boris johnson in camberwell in the
early hours of monday morning police
said the driver suffered minor injuries
the prime minister bought their
four-bedroomed house 1.2 million pounds
in
2019 an mp is among five people killed
in sri lanka in violence following the
prime minister's resignation the country
is experiencing a severe economic crisis
with shortages of food medicine and fuel
and a general strike has been called for
today ashley hernandez reports
the protests that have been challenging
democratic decisions have now faced an
attack themselves
supporters have stormed the growing
protest camp on colombo's seafront a
shame to be a citizen of this country a
shame right now to be born into this
country
slashing tents and beating
anti-government demonstrators in
retaliation vehicles and commercial
buildings have been destroyed and a
number of mp's houses have been set
alight
the military attempted to push back
and after being accused of standing by
police